A HUMAN RIGHTS GROUP SAYS
UKRAINIAN SECURITY FORCES
LAUNCHED A FIERCE ATTACK USING
LIVE AMMUNITION IN A KURDISH
CITIES EARLY ON MONDAY.
THIS COMES AS ANTI-GOVERNMENT
PROTESTS UNDER A FOURTH WEEK.
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
NORTH TEHRAN SANG AN OLD
PATRIOTIC SONG THERE, PALMS
STAINED WITH RED PAINT TO SHOW
SOLIDARITY WITH PROTESTERS.
JOMANA KARDASHIAN HAS BEEN
REPORTING ON THESE PROTESTERS
SINCE THEY BEGAN.
JOINING US NOW FROM ISTANBUL --
JOMANA?
>> YOU KNOW, BECKY, YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS QUITE A
BIT OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS.
IT HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO REPORT ON WHAT IS GOING
ON IN IRAN BECAUSE OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS RESTRICTIONS
WHICH HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE BY
THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF THE
INTERNET SHUT DOWN.
WE REALLY HAVE SEEN A BIT OF
VIDEO, A BIT OF INFORMATION
EMERGE FROM THE COUNTRY.
WE WERE ABLE TO PIECE THAT
TOGETHER.
IT GIVES YOU SOME IDEA OF WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE INDICATIONS AND A LOT
OF CONCERNS THAT WE MIGHT BE
SEEING THIS HARSH CRACKDOWN.
WE ARE SEEING --
A LOT MORE VIDEO WE ARE SEEING
OF REALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
ARRESTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS, WHETHER THEY ARE
PROTESTERS OR NOT PROTESTERS.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE GOVERNMENT
COMING OUT AND SAYING THAT
ANYONE WHO WILL BE DETAINED IS
NOT GOING TO BE RELEASED AS A
PART OF THE PROTESTS.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE A VERY QUICK
TRIAL AND THEY ARE --
PEOPLE REMAIN UNDETERRED, NO
MATTER WHAT THE GOVERNMENT USES
TO TRY TO STOP THEM FROM
JOINING THESE PROTESTS.
WE HAVE TO WARN OUR VIEWERS
THAT SOME OF THE VIDEO IN THE
PIECE IS GRAPHIC AND THEY WILL
FIND IT DISTURBING.
>> THIS IS HOW THE FOURTH WEEK
OF IRAN'S UPRISING STARTED.
THE WAILS OF ONE MORE FAMILIES
FOREVER FAREWELL.
ANOTHER YOUNG LIFE TAKEN TOO
SOON.
ONE OF SEVERAL LIVES LOST IN A
DAY OF CARNAGE IN IRAN'S
KURDISH REGION.
THESE ARE THE IMAGES THE REGIME
DOESN'T WANT THE WORLD TO SEE.
THEY CUT OFF THE INTERNET,
MAKING IT HARD FOR US TO TELL
THE STORIES OF THE DEAD AND
THOSE LEFT TO MOURN.
THE VIDEO TRICKLING OUT IS ONLY
A GLIMPSE INTO THE REPRESSIVE
REPUBLIC AND IT'S VICIOUS
FORCED TO CRASH THE GROWING
DISSENT.
THE SAVAGERY CAUGHT ON CAMERA
IN A SCENES LIKE THIS IN TEHRAN.
AND THIS --
A MAN PLEADS WITH POLICE TO
LEAVE HIS WIFE ALONE.
WE ARE NOT PROTESTING, SHE IS
PREGNANT, HE SAYS.
TO NO AVAIL --
BOTH APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN
FORCIBLY DRAGGED AWAY.
IT IS THAT TYRANNY THAT FEEDS
THE ANGER OF THOSE ON THE
STREETS, DEFIANT AND DETERMINED,
SEEMINGLY UNSTOPPABLE.
I DON'T ALL WOMEN'S UNIVERSITY
THIS WEEKEND, PRESIDENT EBRAHIM
RAISI PRAISED STUDENTS FOR
SEEING THROUGH WHAT HE CLAIMS
IS A FOREIGN CONSPIRACY TO
WEAKEN IRAN.
THAT SAME UNIVERSITY, AN
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT OF
REBELLION AS YOUNG WOMEN CHANT
FOR HIM TO GET LOST.
UNCLEAR THIS HAPPENED WHILE HE
WAS THERE, WHAT IS CLEAR IS THE
WALL OF FEAR IN IRAN HAS COME
TO DOWN.
EVEN THE REGIME'S ATTEMPT TO
CONTROL THE NARRATIVE ALSO
BRIEFLY DISRUPTED HACKERS
INTERRUPTED TO STATE TV
SATURDAY EVENING WITH THIS
VIDEO.
HE TARGET --
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN,
THE FACES OF MASS ARMENIAN
THREE OF THE YOUNG WOMAN WHO
HAVE DIED IN THE PROTESTS.
THE MESSAGE READS, JOIN US AND
RISE UP.
THE STREETS OF TEHRAN WERE
ALREADY RISING UP THAT NIGHT
WITH SOME OF THE LARGEST
PROTESTS IN THE CAPITAL SO FAR.
SCENES REPLICATED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS THE GOVERNMENT
CLAIMS THAT COLUMN HAS BEEN
RESTORED AND THE SO-CALLED
RIOTS ARE MOSTLY OVER.
DAYTIME BROUGHT MORE STUDENTS
BACK OUT, PROTESTING ON
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOUNG SCHOOLGIRLS WITHIN THEIR
FIRST HEAD SCARVES, JOINING IN
IN THE DARING CHANCE.
THEY'RE FEARLESS CRIES FOR
WOMEN, LIFE, FREEDOM
REVERBERATE ALLOWED THROUGH THE
STREETS OF IRAN.